mais d'abord Florent l'insécurité à tour
qui fait débat ou à tel point que le
maire écologiste Emmanuel Denis et le
préfet Patrice Latron ont dû organiser
aujourd'hui une conférence de presse
commune pour se justifier et rassurer on
va y venir mais d'abord tout est parti
de plusieurs pétitions dont une en ligne
qui a récolté plus de 3000 signatures
pour réclamer plus de sécurité dans le
vieux tour des comités de quartier ont
aussi sonn l'alarme dans le quartier
beaujardin cette fois ce sont des
commerçants
écoutez il y a des vols de maisons il y
a
des bah le braquage du du bureau de
tabac il y a des des vol dans les salons
de coiffure et cetera il y a quand même
eu pas mal de de petites choses qui n'y
avaient pas avant à beaujardin j'ai vu
en direct des deal se faire juste en
face mon magasin petite passe et qui le
font qui vous font un signe bonjour
alors qu'on sait très bien qu'ils sont
en train de daler sur la place ça
rassure pas vraiment on a besoin d'une
augmentation du nombre de patrouilles
dans la journée et surtout la nuit et
surtout alors moi j'en ai pas
été enfin j'en ai pas souffert mais
surtout que quand les riverins appellent
les forces de police le soir pour
décrire ce qui se passe qui vienent quoi
la municipalité de tour et la préfecture
ont donc décider de réagir Florent
d'abord en donnant des chiffres oui on
peut citer par exemple celui des
violences physique plus 5 % cette année
plus 13 entre 2021 et 2022 en revanche
et c'est là que c'est intéressant la
plupart des autres indicateurs comme les
vols sont en très nette baisse Emmanuel
deny et Patrice Latron qui ont également
profité de cette conférence de presse
pour faire des annonces Clémence
Dosque incivilité et délinquence les
tourangeau seraiit gagnés par un
sentiment d'insécurité c'est ce
qu'affirme l'opposition à tour en
s'appuyant notamment sur les remontées
des comités de quartier on voit
aujourd'hui depuis 3 3 ans qu'il y a
moins de policiers municipaux sur les
dans les rues de tour pardon qu'il y a 3
ans on voit que la vidéo surveillance
que nous avions installé il y a
maintenant quelques années sert en
partie maintenant à verbaliser plutôt
les automobilistes malgarés plutôt que
les petits voyou trè chose les rapports
entre la police municipale police
nationale très important rapport
évidemment face à la grogne de
l'opposition et l'inquiétude des
habitants la municipalité a décidé de
répondre sans remettre en question le
ressenti des habitants l'objectif c'est
quand même de de réduire l'éclairage de
faire des économie d'énergie mais ça
n'est pas au détriment de la sécurité il
y a pas à avoir de polémique sur ces
sujets là c'est en bonne intelligence
avec les les services de la police
nationale disponible sur le site du
ministère de l'Intérieur les chiffres de
la délinquence sont en N amélioration
depuis 5 ans par rapport à 2022 les vols
dans les voitures ont diminué de 36 %
les vols avec violence de 40 % et ce
sans violence ont baissé de 25 %.
toutefois les atteintes aux personnes on
augmenté de 5 % mais concerne
principalement les violences
intrafamiliales en ce qui concerne la
catégorie des des atteintes aux
personnes on a une tendance à
l'augmentation on
a une augmentation de 5 % des des faits
sur les 8 premiers mois de l'année c'est
une tendance qui est une tendance
nationale côté présence policière le
préfet assure qu'elle a été renforcé
depuis début juillet dans le cadre du
Plan zéro dé laquances mis en
application partout en France il reste
tout de même la question des incibilités
à prendre en compte au-delà de la
sécurité publique il y a la tranquillité
publique il y a des nuisances des
nuisances qui relèvent aussi du défaut
de civisme et donc il faut qu'on
s'attaque aussi à ces nuisances dans les
jours à venir la préfecture sanctionnera
une douzaine d'établissements du
centre-ville pour vente d'alcool en
dehors des heures autorisées ou encore
pour tapage
nocturne